[Music]
hey how's it going
Bruce you may find things are a bit
different
oh I know it looks weird but maybe you
bros like it let's see what you guys
think of my new look
are you kenny from the walking dead [ __ ]
no he is the kazoo Kade how does I'm no
no I'm not the kazoo cake just because I
have a bowl haircut this is what
separates us kazoo kid wish he could
pull this off okay come on he's
obviously drawn Jeremy Jesus Christ why
do you hate me what have I done wrong
for you to treat me like this has the
endless hours of free entertainment and
not been enough okay what what the [ __ ]
how does that make any [ __ ] sense
stop stop no can I try out fresh new
looks without you judging me okay maybe
maybe my girlfriend likes it okay she
doesn't she actually hates it a little
better shave and it looks like Steve
Murphy alright well I'll take it
alright so beyond my absolutely
stunningly beautiful mustache you may
have noticed I switched rooms you may
have noticed there's new logos
everywhere there's an explanation to
that okay this is my new office yeah
that's right we had to move yet again
everyone we had to move office and you
know you guessed it why we got kicked
out we kept getting those complaints
again and we thought well we might as
well get a proper [ __ ] office this is
brand new office I'll show you outside
it's pretty big
pretty massive here we go
Oh Edgar and my so cute what do you do
it I think I said merci
thank you
Oh realgar phone go away this is my wife
in seven hundred years she will look
just like this young however will look
like Dustin bones okay new office hype
it's so big
it's so huge we even have the floor
downstairs I'll show you that in a bit
basically this office used to be Club
Penguin's office which is owned by
Disney and when we got it all this stuff
is still here it's kind of funny we're
probably gonna get rid of all the stuff
it's kind of I really hello I'm here I
really want to set up kind of like we
did cringe miss we have a studio that we
rented and that costs a shit-ton so we
figured we'd save money to set something
like this up her own abyss mean well wow
yeah so nice is that the one in Japan
great follow me for continuous room tour
so my company rebel mode is what owns
this building now I guess or renting it
so anyone part of rebel mode can come
and set up which they won't I don't know
why I haven't seen it I'm here I want I
wanna but the possibilities are endless
let's go downstairs so this is the
urinal this is where LP that's very nice
this is where I'll put my penis sorry
okay let's move on Eggar
[Music]
come on follow me along I don't know
what to do
yeah you like it you have to say that
you like it because otherwise I you know
you hurtin see might still like said
that's all that matters to me yeah
what's that
okay okay no they must be oh that's so
sad
bye-bye they were finally really sad
when they move down but Club Penguin I
want you to know that we will honor your
legacy we will make this place shine
again for your for your sake if you have
ideas leave comments down below what we
can do with this cuz I honestly I don't
know what to do
are you swimming in on my face are you
gonna good-bye Marcia bye Oh so yeah we
moved office right before Christmas it
was really intense I made the video in
LA where I said it I was really
everything was really stressing and
messing honestly ever since I got back
from Los Angeles it feels like we
haven't really had a chance to catch up
yet because we had so many things to do
you know you only see the videos but
there's so much going I don't mean to
pry or whatever and be like but there's
so much stuff going on behind the scenes
and even if I try and explain it it's
not really you know it doesn't really
matter that
but at the same time there's a lot going
on that's all you need to know but it's
really good I feel a lot better since I
Los Angeles there's still been really
stressed but it's been good stress I've
been really happy to focus on my channel
literally November was my worst month
ever thanks to the YouTube glitch which
they still haven't acknowledged but it
seemed like it fixed itself in December
because I went from my worst month to my
best month and it's really thanks to you
guys for for watching the videos and
showing your support it really makes a
difference and it makes all like the
intense intensity and stress worth it it
made it so much fun i december was such
a great month and i really really
enjoyed it and i owe such a huge thanks
to you guys for right now i I want to be
more thankful than that just that but I
can't and you know it's i watch other
channels that are just so nice and like
you watch them and they thank their fans
and it's just like but when I do it I'm
just like no thanks I guess I don't know
I don't have it in me but it really does
mean the world to me I don't know how
else to say it
alright just [ __ ]
here we go
I never I have no idea what you do what
are you doing this game
while I see how they couldn't afford
this office now I just I just wanted to
say bye to everyone in the game I'm
gonna say goodbye to all the club
penguins here we are in in Club Penguin
everyone are these old players there am
i there there's me carrot care fish
there's sixteen DK goodbye Sarah you
look beautiful
goodbye p3 is for four goodbye goodbye
p3 for for good bye
p3 for for goodbye goodbye goodbye
goodbye goodbye everyone goodbye
everyone goodbye goodbye
[Music]
did i disappoint you
I'll let you down should I be feeling
guilty you touch my [ __ ]
goodbye club penguin goodbye my friend I
have got your office I have got your
rough is now goodbye my club penguin you
by my friend alright that's ten minutes
we can